during my live coverage last night of
Donald Trump's propaganda fake
immigration crisis border wall primetime
national address I took a call from a
viewer who asked me when are we going to
hear from Republicans that the shutdown
has gone far enough
that government needs to be reopened
without funding for the wall and last
night I said if the shutdown starts to
stretch into February that will start to
impact people's ability to receive their
tax refunds if that becomes a question
mark that is going to light a fire under
the rear ends of some Republicans if the
TSA funding issues start to lead to
airport shutdowns and [ __ ] air travel
which of course relates to so many
different industries you will see at
least some Republicans say we have to
reopen government without border wall
funding and we're sort of starting to
see that now although it's really
important to remember that just because
a Republican says they want to reopen
government without funding for the
border wall we have to wait to see if
they actually vote to do so or if it's
even possible for them to vote to do so
and here's exactly what I mean
the people the three Republican senators
who are now saying we are looking we are
interested in reopening government
without border wall funding our
Republican senators lisa murkowski susan
collins and cory gardner they are saying
let's reopen the government even if we
don't have border wall funding secured
the fact that it is those three makes
perfect sense because susan collins is
up for reelection in 2020 she suffered
significantly because of her involvement
in the Brett Kavanaugh confirmation
fiasco she's at real risk from the
moderate Republican voters in Maine of
not being reelected in 2020 she now says
she sees no reason why the bills that
are ready to go and on which they've
achieved agreement should be held
hostage to the debate over border
security Cory Gardner I've mentioned him
before he's a Republican in Colorado the
purple or sort of blueish state of
Colorado
he's also up for re-election in 2020 he
is one of the most at-risk Republican
senators for reelection in 2020 he now
says I think we should pass a continuing
resolution to get the government back
and then you have number three Lisa
Murkowski who's not up for reelection in
2020 but she's generally one of the more
moderate Republicans in the Senate and
she likes to be seen as an independent
thinker whether or not she actually is
one she says we don't need to hold up
six departments simply to resolve border
security issues so as I've mentioned
before it's lovely it's delightful that
they are saying this but three
Republican votes is not really enough to
pass this bill in the Senate or any of
the bills that we're talking about so
this is a very safe thing that they can
do they can get the public relations
optics benefit of saying we want to end
the shutdown we don't need to have the
power we don't need to have the border
wall in place in order to do it but they
don't actually have the ability the
power to go against Trump and get
government open back up
if Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell won't bring the bills to a
vote it doesn't matter whether susan
collins would vote to reopen government
whether cory gardner would vote to
reopen government because number one
they're not getting a vote and number
two even with their vote it wouldn't be
enough to get government reopened so i
understand why they're doing this after
the brett Cavanaugh Fiasco with Susan
Collins I simply don't trust her Pat I
mean she will say one thing to appeal to
the moderate voters in Maine but then in
the end she'll just go along with the
massive Republican senators on so many
issues yeah for now we're definitely at
a standstill but ultimately I don't
think it's gonna be up to Murkowski
Collins and Gardner if the government
reopens anytime soon I think that House
Democrats of course have no reason to
give in I think Trump is so stubborn
that he's going to try to keep this
going and we're actually now I think at
serious risk of this going on for months
or even up to a year who knows because
there's just no incentive to compromise
on this one well Donald Trump is being
put into a more and more difficult
position fortunately because he is going
to at some point maybe have to either
relent and let government get opened
again without border funding or he's
going to have to keep this thing going
which could become a court battle
it could cause political consequences
that are not good for Trump and
Republicans in 2020 and as far as
responsibility goes we have new poll
data which yes it shows that 47 percent
of voters blame Trump for the shutdown
and five percent blame Republicans
that's 52 total 33 percent blame
Democrats the rest aren't sure or are
sort of split that's sort of good news
because it is Trump's fault so it's good
that a plurality understand that but it
is extraordinarily disturbing that
one-third of voters think Democrats are
to blame for a shutdown that Trump
promised on camera and then subsequently
did but I don't know maybe 47% is better
than it could be and we should just be
glad for that but I think that there are
a couple of ways that this thing could
go many of which don't involve Trump
getting money for the wall the question
increasingly that is being discussed by
Trump Trump's inner circle is less and
less how to actually get the funding for
the wall but more and more how to get
out of this quagmire saving face and not
appearing to be the poor negotiator beta
male whatever terminology you want to
apply to it the Donald Trump actually is
given the fact that he had no clue what
on earth he was getting into by forcing
this shut down will we know tomorrow
will we know next week will we know next
month I genuinely have no idea but the
longer it goes the more people that will
be incentivized to say Trump's really
screwing me over with this thing to the
extent they believe that Trump is at
fault
I'm not gonna vote for him or
Republicans in 2020 and that's the
political risk that builds over time